[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo vous connaissez le
principe on va refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire question
politique c'était une semaine sous
tension bonjean catllar bonjour michael
we sous tension de semaine que l'on va
commenter avec notre invité olivier faur
bonjour je vends des deux président du
groupe socialiste et républicain à
l'assemblée merci d'être notre avis tu
écologiste écolo jsr au nom de code
on parlera de françois fillon toujours
dans l'oeil du cyclone et des
conséquences de cette affaire pour la
droite
et puis en pleine affaire fillon
l'assemblée a justement voté deux textes
pour renforcer la transparence en
matière d'élections et on parlera aussi
de la difficile mission qui s'annonce
pour benoît hamon qui va tenter de
rassembler son camp et la gauche
éventuellement
olivier faur indexé semaine un petit peu
j'étais va commencer évidemment par le
feuilleton françois fillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle le candidat des
républicains poursuit sa campagne comme
si de rien n'était il était jeudi en
meeting à charleville mézières dans les
ardennes
béatrice faisant et marion châtelaine au
suivi ardennes tient ferme c'est la
devise d'un régiment de l'armée
ce sera désormais celle de françois
fillon qui poursuit coûte que coûte sa
campagne sous les applaudissements
françois fillon est décidé à se battre
et ils lancent un appel clair à ses
militants oui mes amis je vous demande
de m'aider à résister les yeux rougis
le candidat à la présidentielle consacre
les premières minutes de son discours au
pénélope kate
ces attaques ne sortent pas de nulle
part elles ont été soigneusement préparé
des accusations faites selon françois
fillon pour casser la droite éprouve une
colère froide face à toute cette meute
qui se complaît dans cette entreprise de
démolition ses soutiens dénoncent eux un
acharnement médiatique
évidemment tout le monde est choqué on
est choqué de voir ce que vous faites
vous les médias vous êtes en train de
vouloir à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
candidats de droite aux élections
présidentielles ce n'est pas normal
malgré cette affaire hors de question
pour ces soutiens de laisser tomber
françois fillon tout le monde ne fait
pas pareil
je crois qu'il n'y a pas que lui je
crois que si on voulait creuser un peu
partout je pense qu'on découvrirait
énormément de très vilaines choses c'est
des emplois présumés fictifs mais ça ça
n'existe pas juridiquement pour
l'instant il est présumé innocent donc
contraire à on est là pour la soutenir
pour lui montrer qu'on est qu'on veut
absolument qu'il aille jusqu'au bout
mais quelques voix dissonantes se font
également entendre signe d'un public pas
totalement acquis à sa cause
hier soir ce sont trois personnes qui
ont été exclus du meeting françois
fillon continue sa campagne pourtant au
sein même de son parti les républicains
certains lui réclame des comptes
olivier faur s'engage six français sur
dix pensent que françois fillon devrait
renoncer à sa candidature
est ce que vous comprenez le doute des
français bien sûr que je comprends le
doute et d'ailleurs je pense que
françois fillon aurait dû lui même le
lever ce doute n'ont pas honte de dire
non pas en expliquant que des complots
partout parce que ça relève de
l'argument classique de ceux qui n'ont
plus d'arguments mais au contraire en
affichant les témoignages les mails je
fis données des disques durs et de dire
'voilà regarder ma femme a travaillé
pour moi pendant plus de dix ans je peux
être qui a été fait pourquoi ne le
fait-il pas devant les français eux
mêmes en leur disant mais un problème de
colonne était sûrement sa part plus que
les primes de communication il ya un
problème de rapport
visiblement à la vérité et donc moi je
souhaite que françois fillon puisse se
disculper si c'est possible
les meilleurs délais parce que cette
crise est une crise pour la droite c'est
une crise plus large aussi parce
qu'elles touchent finalement l'ensemble
des parlementaires dont la réputation
entachée par ce qui apparaît comme un
emploi fictif vous pensez qu'il peut
aller jusqu'au bout malgré tout cette
cette colère de certains des militants
de droite et du désarroi de députés de
droite pensait qu'il n'est pas empêché
ce n'est pas à moi de le dire mais tant
qu'il n'aura pas effectivement fournie
preuve de ce qu'ils le publiquement
publiquement au skill et explique aux
français à savoir qu'il est innocent et
que l'emploi n'étaient pas fictifs
il sera confronté dans toute cette
campagne à des questions de votre part
parce qu'elles sont légitimes et que les
français sont en droit de savoir quel
est l'homme qui veut représenter la
droite dans cette élection vous dit tout
à l'heure un instant un problème avec la
vérité ne dit pas la vérité une cache la
vérité selon vous mais je ne veux pas je
il est plus didier mais je prends
simplement les éléments qu'il a donné
lui même quand il est venu en plateau à
la télévision sur une grande chaîne de
télévision il a dit j'ai fait travailler
les enfants sur des missions ponctuelles
et il était déjà avocat il n'était ni
avocat était étudiant en droit à
l'époque et c'était pas des missions
ponctuelles mais des contrats en compte
des contrats en contrats à durée
indéterminée donc premier mensonge
ensuite sur les moments où sa femme a
travaillé pour lui il expliqué qu'elle
travaillait je me souviens plus des
dates précises mais la réalité c'est que
sa femme avait déjà travaillé pour lui à
une époque où il l'a déclaré sur sky
télévision comme bénévole ben on voit
bien que se succèdent les mensonges les
uns après les autres et que aujourd'hui
la défaite mensonge aujourd'hui bien sûr
il ya des mensonges
pour cela ils sont déjà prouvé pour le
reste moi je m'en tiens là j'ai ce que
je peux dire la justice et je ne veux
pas me transférer moi même en nous aux
coureurs mais j'ai simplement que la
seule façon pour françois fillon de se
disculper
c'est d'apporter aux français la preuve
de ce qu'il avance pour l'instant ça
risque que ça c'est grâce à des morceaux
d'être extrêmement difficile et pénible
pour lui alors cette semaine françois
fillon a au contraire dénoncé un coup
institutionnels venu de la gauche contre
lui le conseiller stratégique de sa
campagne bernard debré a même cibler un
homme jean louis nadal président de la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique nommé par françois
hollande
écoutez cet extrait sur notre antenne
l'image a été construite par une
officine je ne sais pas laquelle a en
fait s'en va on va unir
vous ne savez pas laquelle moi je suis
pour laquelle vous imaginez que monsieur
le foll va dire c'est moi qui ai fait
venir vous est-ce que vous avez des
preuves aujourd'hui que ce soit un
gouffre on n'a pas de preuves mais
reversing pourquoi avancer que c'est une
officine est ce qu'on est en train de
chercher qu'on a des suspects
non mais c'est quoi ces suspicions mais
ces suspicions c'est monsieur nadal qui
a été nommé par le gouvernement
c'est monsieur le un conseiller de
françois hollande qui est là pour ça et
on le sait bien officie une suspicion
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa
illuminati cette thèse du complot
permanent enfin puisque c'est fantasque
mais c'est pas feinte à ce que c'est là
encore un argument très éculés en
réalité à chaque fois vous avez
quelqu'un qui est pris dans les filets
de la justice
il explique que c'est forcément un
complot d'officine cabinet noir qui
serait là ils travailleraient dans le
secret dans l'ombre des puissants et
qu'ils seraient là pour déstabiliser
n'existe pas sa peau mais non ça
n'existe pas c'est une faute de la part
de parlementaires républicains bien sûr
et même d'incriminer celui qui est
aujourd'hui en responsabilité de la
haute autorité la transparence est une
institution qui a été créée après l
affaire cahuzac et qui a justement pour
vocation de venir débusquer et les
mensonges les fraudes et c'est dire que
l'officine c'est précisément
l'institution qui a pour charge de
vérifier contrôler les parlementaires et
plus largement les mains de cabinets
ministériels les grands élus etc
c'est quand même assez étonnant parce
que nadal son boulot c'est précisément
celui là c'est de faire la lumière sur
d'éventuelles fraudes
il pourrait avoir été pratiquée parce
que on le sait bien on parle souvent de
la république exemplaire la réplique
exemple assez quoi c'est pas le fait que
désormais vous n'ayez plus que des oies
blanches qui se présentent au suffrage
universel
vous ne pouvez pas le savoir vous ne
pouvez pas savoir qui vous avez face à
vous quand vous les lisez en revanche ce
que vous pouvez faire c'est les
contrôler et quand vous voulez contrôler
y compris aller jusqu à les sanctionner
s'ils ont manqué à leur parole vous vous
sentez que j'avoue c'est aujourd'hui par
cette affaire je vous dis pas le beau
scandale mais par cette affaire oui
parce qu'il ya un courant de suspicion
dans votre reportage à l'instant une
femme dit mais en réalité si on creuse
et honoré par tous et ça moi ce que
d'abord première chose c'est que tout on
n'est pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et ça suppose
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle d'accepter l'idée qu'on
vienne fouiller dans votre passé dans
votre histoire dans votre moralité pour
aller jusqu'à dire comme on dit oui en
quoi ce scanner effectivement et je
pense que c'est assez logique et ensuite
c'est vrai que ce qui est difficile
c'est j'ai été interrogé hier par vos
confrères du parisien
pour me demander si moi j'avais embauché
des gens de ma famille non non je n'ai
jamais embauché pour quiconque de ma
famille mais je veux dire par là c'est
que désormais pèse à suspicion générale
sur escaut embaucher des gens leur
famille s'ils sont votre mii est ce
qu'ils sont éventuellement un emploi
fictif
comment est-ce que c'est justement fait
lourd je me lance justement vous
entendre présent d'un président de
groupe est ce que vous lancez ce platon
appel solennel à tous les députés
d'arrêter de d'embaucher un membre de la
famille ou en tout cas d'être très
claires sur ces embauches là qui pose
problème quand même moi je suis pour que
ce soit dans ma famille politique ou
ailleurs les règles soient respectées
pour l'instant la règle légale c'est
qu'on peut embaucher quelqu'un mais de
sa famille sa famille qu'il faudrait pas
aller plus loin
moi je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
et faire comme au parlement européen
comme au bundestag où cette possibilité
là est interdite mais je comprends aussi
ce qu'ils disent mais moi ça fait 20 ans
que j'ai milité que ma femme on a tous
construire ensemble et serrage n'avait
pas été choqué quand cécilia sarkozy
travaille avec nicolas sarkozy ça
paraissait logique dans la vie qu'avec
ensuite en ce sens il faut par exemple
une mère pour interdire ou pas
d'embauché benoît hamon et je pense
qu'il faut effectivement le suisse au
plan là mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que si on avait demain quelqu'un de mon
propre parti dont on découvrait qu'il
avait couvert un emploi fictif
je serai aussi sévère qu'avec françois
fillon parce que c'est possible c'est ce
qui mine la confiance dans ce que nous
sommes collectivement à travailler ça
d'image pour les politiques c'est
toujours à chaque fois avec des
conséquences qui sont le lorient de
risque pour nous c'est de faire grimper
le vote rct protestataires les
populismes
et on voit bien ce à quoi ça peut mener
dans d'autres pays je pense évidemment
aux états unis avec un président dont
tout le monde se demande chaque jour
quelle est la nouvelle catastrophe qu'il
va décider donc je n'aimerais pas que ça
puisse arriver dans nos propres pays
alors hasard du calendrier c'est en
pleine affaire fillon que les députés
olivier faure ont débattu de deux
propositions de loi pour renforcer la
transparence de la vie politique compte
rendu de séance avec green benameur en
finir avec l'idée du tous pourris ou à
la l'objectif de deux propositions de
loi adopté à l'unanimité par les députés
la plus importante l'obligation d'avoir
un casier judiciaire vierge pour toute
personne se présentant à une élection
locale ou nationale
comment admettre que des individus
auteurs de faits révélant un manque de
considération à l'égard de la
collectivité
un défaut de civisme dans la gestion des
affaires de tous puis solliciter les
suffrages des français
hasard du calendrier ce texte arrive en
pleine affaire françois fillon une
actualité très présente dans l'hémicycle
bruno le roux fait partie des députés
qui sont à l'origine de cette
proposition de loi
devenu ministre de l'intérieur entre
temps il défend un texte essentiel pour
la démocratie engagements du
gouvernement en matière de transparence
et de moralisation de la vie publique
est totale et je remercie une nouvelle
fois madame la rapporteure de nous
permettre d'en débattre à nouveau
d'ajouter une pierre à l'édifice
républicain patiemment construit je dis
cela aujourd'hui avec la gravité qui va
avec les débats qui sont ceux de notre
pays au moment où je vous parle et il ya
consensus autour de cette proposition de
loi les républicains montrent aussi
soutenu les députés de l'est républicain
votre recette texte sans ambiguïté nous
sommes nombreux à nous consacrer à nos
mandats avait rigueur toiture et dignité
mais nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
de laisser les actes d'une minorité
jeter l'opprobre sur toute la classe
politique
touché par le spectre de la défiance
l'autre texte adopté visé
vite et les candidats malgré eux en
rendant obligatoire la signature avant
toute candidature
une mesure visant surtout l'extrême
droite sans surprise les deux textes ont
été adoptés en première lecture mais peu
de chances qu'ils le soient
définitivement avant la fin de la
session parlementaire fin février voilà
donc nouvelles règles avec notamment une
obligation de casier judiciaire vierge
pour tout le monde mais les ministres ne
sont pas concernés par ces nouvelles
règles est ce que pour vous c'est un
problème c'est n'oublie que nous
pourrions corrigé maintenant moi je
souhaiterais que ce texte puisse être
adoptée de la vie avant ils oublient que
vous pouvez corriger
ben c'est à dire que je pense
qu'effectivement casier judiciaire âge
il s'impose en réalité pour tout le
monde et que ya pas de fonction publique
qui ne doivent pas passer par ce tamis
là par ce filtre là mais c'est vrai que
les par contre le groupe socialiste et
les propositions de loi nous là nous
l'avons pensé pour les élus et manière à
ce que quand on se présente aux
suffrages des électeurs on ne puisse pas
le faire
voilà donc il faut certainement ajouter
une autre proposition de loi plus tard
mais je ne voudrais pas que parce que
nous avons sommes dans une période très
contrainte en termes de durée de temps
puisque si on s'arrête fin février c'est
pas sûr que ce projet hongrois
c'est cette proposition nous avons 5 6
on ne peut pas demander au sénat
d'amender à son tour pour faire revenir
donc moi je préférais que le sénat
adopte conforme ce kilomètre et
l'adoption immédiate de ce texte
et puis quand la prochaine législature
nous y revenons et vous avez raison de
dire que pour les fonctions des
fonctions ministérielles la même règle
s'impose vous simplement des liens aussi
avec le sénat ce qui est des chances
pour que ce texte soit adopté pour la
fin de la législature et coûté jusqu'ici
la droite n'avait jamais adopté les
textes sur la transparence en 2013 après
africain visa que nous avons été seul à
adopter les nouvelles règles haute
autorité le parquet financier les
obligations faites de transparence pour
chaque parlementaire est d'ailleurs
françois fillon vous l'aviez remarqué
avec
jusque là une employée qui s'appelait
pénélope fillon le jour où il a été
obligé de rendre transparente le nom de
ses collaborateurs son contrat est
interrompue mais c'était juste une
remarque une parenthèse mais donc j'ai
oublié ce que je voulais vous dire mais
que jusque là en tout cas la gauche oui
que je sors effet c'est là où j'ai fait
la seule la droite à vos textes
aujourd'hui la droite a voté donc ça
veut dire que au sénat à la droite étant
majoritaire elle a la possibilité de
faire en sorte que cette proposition
soit définitivement adopté avant la fin
de la session
vous leur demandez aujourd'hui je
redemande solennellement effectivement
de le faire parce que je crois que ça
paraît évident il ya des tas de
profession qui sont professions
réglementées dans lesquels vous ne
pouvez pas postuler parce que vous avez
un casier est là pour une fonction qui
comme celle d'écrire la loi ou celles de
gérer une collectivité locale
vous pouvez arriver qu'un casiers
remplis ce qui est absolument absurde 1
il y à ces deux nouveaux textes il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de législation pour
rendre la vie politique plus
transparente
on a l'impression que malgré tout ça est
bien le sentiment d'impunité est
toujours là comment vous l'expliquez
vous en parliez il ya quelques minutes
pourquoi ce sentiment d'impunité des
élus que peuvent avoir le que peut avoir
l'opinion
alors on explique c'est le paradoxe
parce que justement il n'y a plus
d'impunité
autrefois il n'y aurait pas eu la sphère
cahuzac
il n'y aurait pas eu d'affairé fillon
les temps changent et vous non oui les
temps ont changé parce que justement il
ya désormais des contrôles s'il n'y
avait pas de contrôle
on ne saurait pas on n'aurait jamais su
sens à la fois le travail qu'a réalisé
après ce que nous avons aussi une presse
indépendante et dans les deux cas à
chaque fois on a mis à part tout le
canard enchaîné qui sont à l'origine de
tout ça mais ensuite on a une justice
qui agi avec célérité on a notre côté
une haute autorité qui aussi créer les
conditions en fait de débusquer les
éventuels fraudeurs appel que quand
canard enchaîné explique comment ils ont
trouvé la sphère pénélope fillon ils
disent que c'est parce qu'ils ont repéré
dans les contradictions des déclaration
officielle faite à françois fillon des
raisons d'enquêté et c'est comme ça
qu'est né leur enquête
bon on voit bien que tout ça c'est né de
ces lois et donc est aujourd'hui la
justice elle passe c'est ça la
différence
la réplique exemple à ça ne peut pas
être encore une fois comment est-ce que
si demain vous êtes candidate comment
est ce que je sais moi
si demain je suis présent la république
et que vous êtes d'un ministre comment
je sais si vous êtes vierge de tout
fraude au sens très bien à ces autorités
au total a donc désormais ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il y avait une haute autorité
qui travaillent et puis si on trouve
quelque chose sur sur vous eh bien on a
une justice qui passe alors qu'autrefois
on régler ça dans les cabinets c'était
tranquille on s'arrangeait pour que
d'icera et rien ne se voyait tous se
posent aux de transparence olivier faur
de passer à votre parti parti socialiste
et notamment à benoît hamon après sa
victoire de dimanche dernier c'est dans
un instant benoît hamon qui va tenter de
rassembler son camp la chose ne sera
peut-être pas si facile que cela il a
rencontré notamment les élus de toutes
tendances cette semaine on voit tout
cela un crime benameur la victoire de
benoît hamon n'en finit plus de diviser
les socialistes l'ailé droite du parti
appelé aussi réformateur s'est réuni ce
mardi à l'assemblée une réunion
exceptionnelle mais aussi une tribune
publiée dans le monde 17 députés l'ont
signé il juge la candidature de benoît
hamon trop radicalisées à gauche et
évoque un droit de retrait on ne met pas
en cause la personne de benoît hamon
avec lequel moi j'ai travaillé sur les
sujets internationaux mais son programme
n'est pas acceptable n'est pas vendable
n'est pas défendable ne lui permet pas
d'aller au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
or nous notre objectif c'est d'aller au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle pour éviter fillon le pen
les soutiens de benoît hamon eux en
appel à la cohérence quand on s'est
engagé dans le processus des primaires
on s'est engagé à choisir un candidat ou
une candidate parmi 7 et une orientation
derrière c'est ce candidat et cette
orientation qui doivent poursuivre la
dynamique dans l'élection présidentielle
les autres députés socialistes tentent
de minimiser la division et appelle à
l'unité à nous nos désaccords ou nos
accords
l'histoire dit socialiste et puis
ce qui est en train de se passer à
droite où on peut se retrouver
collectivement dans situation
démocratique extraordinairement
difficile donc il faut aussi enfin moi
je tout faire
dans cette période pour que on reste
deux groupes et la question omniprésente
c'est combien de députés vont rallier la
candidature d'emmanuel macron pour
l'instant ils seraient 4 ou 5 mais
d'autres pourraient suivre
alors olivier farine à de nombreuses
questions à vous poser mais cette
semaine benoît hamon a rencontré le
président de la république françois
hollande à l'elysée
cette rencontre était attendue notamment
aussi par les médias et j'imagine aussi
par votre camp écoutez la réaction
birman à sa sortie y a pas de passage de
témoin aujourd'hui
une élection présidentielle est un
président qui préside jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle est ce que sera la
passation de pouvoir après l'élection
présidentielle n'y a pas de passage de
témoin il ya simplement la volonté de ma
part de d'échanger sur ce que seront
les axes de ma campagne et ils seront
dans la continuité de ce que j'ai
défendu on a une plainte non pas des
conseils de campagne on a eu des
éclairages extrêmement précieux sur la
situation européenne et est sûre plus
globalement les relations avec nos
alliés et partenaires voilà benoît hamon
le succès sur l'héritier je sais pas ça
comme ça c'est pas chacun sait bien que
benoît s'est opposé parfois de manière
frontale à sa vente de projet présenté
par l'exécutif mais en même temps c'est
fini tout ça
la page est tournée non c'est un exemple
tourner les pages en fait on écrit de
nouvelles pages en feutre et c il ya des
choses qui se sont passées
chacun les connaît et des désaccords ces
désaccords subsistent voit pas très bien
pourquoi on devrait laisser s'efface pas
moi même je n'ai pas enfin je soutiens
aujourd'hui benoît émond candidats et de
manière totale je m'engage derrière lui
et en même temps ça veut pas dire que je
n'ai pas de différence avec lui
heureusement on est encore dans un pays
libre on a droit de penser mais en même
temps c'est lui qui a gagné l'élection
primaire c'est lui qui a la légitimité
et c'est lui qui a ouvert des pistes qui
sont les pistes que je pensais sur votre
pacte avec lui voilà permanent en plus
en tout cas je le connais bien oui
depuis surtout depuis longtemps ils ont
tant aimé nous nous sommes souvent
combattu puisqu'en fait fait allusion au
fait que il ya maintenant très longtemps
nous avons été colocataires pendant
trois ans et donc effectivement jeu pour
en raconter beaucoup sur ses jeunes
années
mais mais mais commence à se présenter
pendant 25 ans de nous sommes opposés
dans les combats du parti socialiste
parce que nous n'avions pas tout à fait
la même vision et en même temps moi je
suis respectueux à la fois du suffrage
nous avons nous même sollicité des
français plus de deux millions de
français se sont déplacés et ont fait un
choix et ensuite je reconnais aussi a
besoin une capacité
une intuition et puis une volonté de
fédérer qui peut se traduire dans les
prochaines semaines je vois que ça se
traduit aujourd'hui dans le
on voit qui monte il est prêt je vois
18% c'est un sondage évidemment mais
bien sûr ça sondage m'enfin ça indique
une tendance
on est quand on passe de rien à 18%
c'est plutôt bon signe
est ce que ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
n'est plus du tout question de se
retirer au profit des manuels macro mais
si on avait un candidat qui étaient 1 5%
je comprendrais que la question se pose
6 5% là était de nature à faire basculer
les maquereaux au second tour alors que
la gauche n'a aucune autre chance je
pouvais le comprendre aujourd'hui cette
question ne se pose plus et se pose
d'autant moins que nous ne savons
toujours pas qui est emmanuel macron et
keane à son projet et s'il est le
candidat d'une gauche libérale ou est-ce
qu'il est le candidat de substitution
pour une droite orphelins et son
candidat
alors justement va essayer de voir ce
que peut faire de noix amont et avec qui
je vous propose d'accueillir tout de
suite notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
bonjour mathilde siro bonjour caceres
vous êtes avec toute cette semaine c'est
à vous pour cinq minutes
alors bonjour olivier forges on l'a dit
et benoît hamon veut rassembler toute sa
famille politique il devrait s'exprimer
devant le groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée et au sénat dès la semaine
prochaine a priori vous prendra aussi la
parole quel message vous attendez de lui
devant les troupes
les députés socialistes il fait d'abord
s'écrivait dimanche quand il sera
officiellement investi par le parti
socialiste donc ce sera un discours
attendu et moi je souhaite qu'il fasse
la démonstration de ce qu'il est c'est à
dire de quelqu'un qui a à la fois à
développer une vision et en même temps
qui est capable d'entendre ce que
d'autres lui disent et donc qui peut
approfondir son projet en entendant ce
que sont notamment les experts qui
appartiennent aux deux groupes
parlementaires assemblée sénat
et je crois qu'il en a la volonté est-ce
que ça risque pas d'être un petit peu
tendu on a vu cette semaine qu'il y
avait des députés légitimiste réforme
réformateurs qui souhaitent regarder
peut-être du côté des manuels maquereau
ou en tout cas ne pas soutenir benoît
hamon comment est ce que vous allez
composer avec cette fronde cette
nouvelle fronde sam de fronde à l'envers
maintenant au sein du groupe
d'abord je crois pas que ce soit des
frondeurs ils ont dit eux mêmes qu'ils
ne voulaient pas fondées il sera parti
chez emmanuel macron contrairement à ce
qu'on veut annoncer vous avez là ni tout
de suite ni je pense jamais vous pensez
mais nous partirons pas moi je ne pense
pas que je pense qu'il ya forcément des
risques qui peut-être sont hantées et
partiront ensuite pas kendra aucun mais
je les avais quantifier le nombre de
personnes qui pourraient partir mais
assez peu d'ailleurs on le voit bien les
réformateurs seront seize député un
sénateur s'est quand même fait sur 288
députés socialistes écologistes et
républicains c'est relativement on peut
penser que ça sera un mouvement limité
comme ça pas plus
et c'est d'autant plus limité que le
seul cas de figure où vous cette
question pouvait se poser de manière
importante c'était l'hypothèse d'un
décrochage complet du candidat
socialiste et d'un emmanuel macron qui
n'arrive pas seul au second tour il ya
besoin du soutien du parti socialiste
pour pouvoir passer la barre et éviter
un duel fillon le pen
c'est effectivement la pression était
très forte sur ce que nous sommes parce
que nous aurait dit mais dans ces cas là
vous pouvez éviter un duel droite
extrême droite ça c'est pas votre gauche
emmanuel macron mais enfin ce serait
quand même mieux que fillon l'opl cette
hypothèse là est en train de s'évanouir
puisque en réalité
emmanuel macron et benoît hamon sont au
coude à coude on est dans la marge
d'erreur que nous avons à françois
fillon qui est quand même dans une
situation très compliquée et voyez
benoît ont passé devant rien et l'autre
moi je pense qu'il passera devant l'un
et l'autre et que ce sera la surprise de
cette élection présidentielle mais
benoit avoue président aulas à public
alors oui parce que c'est un candidat
qui n'est pas un candidat ambiguë et je
pense que les français ont besoin à la
fois de quelqu'un qui affirme des
convictions qui développe une vision de
long terme pas seulement le nez collé
sur les trois prochaines années
mais quelqu'un qui prime c'est benoît
hamon président de la république en mai
prochain nous annonce rien parce que je
suis respectueux et toujours du suffrage
des français tu reçoives et pour
l'instant ça vous fait rire mais le 12
mai je remarque quand même que il ya
quelques années quand françois hollande
et hassan poussant il faisait rire tout
le monde est devenu président quand
jacques chirac était candidat et que
tout le monde pensait qu'il était
totalement plombé
il est devenu quand il est nouvelle et
ouvert et donc je pense que benoît hamon
sera source de ces scrutins et nous en
reparlerons peut-être au moins de
motivation en berne avec peut venir ici
pour parler avec votre question olivier
faur vous avez parlé de la commission
d'investiture qui se déroule dimanche
est ce que vous y serez vous voyez bien
sûr alors beaucoup deux ministres
entendent boycotter cette commission est
ce que vous leur lancer un appel pour
qu'il soit présent dimanche au moins je
lance pas d'appel
vous êtes président le groupe non mais
je vais aussi un portrait inédit donc je
ne vais pas je n'ai pas je ne sais pas
j'ai je n'ai pas vocation à donner des
injonctions acquis que cela reste qu'ils
ont tort de ne pas venir mais je pense
que avec défiance mais je pense que le
mieux pour chacun c'est de venir à cette
cause de cette convention parce que et
c'est une convention importante au cours
de laquelle nous allons une sacrée
des résultats et en même temps un
candidat dernière question un mot sur
emmanuel macron vous êtes un proche de
jean marc ayrault
le ministre a déjà fait savoir qu
emmanuel macron était un homme de gauche
est ce que vous seriez surpris qu'ils
soutiennent emmanuel macron oui et je
moi aussi je pense que même la crau est
un homme qui vient de la gauche ce qui
là est ce que je ne sais pas d'où vient
emmanuel macron sait où il va parce que
je n'ai aucun problème avec ça je sais
très bien que neil mac route un homme de
gauche très estimable très intelligent
charismatique tous âges et le concept
très volontiers mais pour l'instant je
ne sais pas où il va et la question
d'une action présidentielle c'est pas de
savoir d'où on vient
moi je n'ai jamais été de ceux qui
considéraient que parce qu'il avait été
banquier et pourrait pas être un homme
de gauche ça me paraît ridicule mais en
même temps mon problème c'est de savoir
où ils nous emmènent et moi je préfère
les idées claires je préfère les gens
qui affiche la couleur plutôt que ceux
qui vous qui passez l'élection
présidentielle dans l'ambiguïté pour
nous emmener un endroit qu'on découvre
lendemain d'élections et bien ce serait
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup olivier
faur d'avoir été l'invité de par le
macbook merci au sérum prochaine
[Musique]
bonjour ma première réforme concrète et
positive en tant que présidente serait
de donner plus de pouvoir aux régions
ça permettrait déjà d'accélérer les
décisions mais aussi de rapprocher les
citoyens de décision donc de les
impliquer davantage dans la vie
politique pour une démocratie plus
directe
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
le repas s'est pas simplement manger se
retrouver
manger très bon sans parler c'est que je
pense que c'est mon nom qui est
important dans notre mode d'alimentation
en france c'est autant ce qu'on a dans
l'assiette que ce qui est autour les
manières de manger et ils repassaient ce
qui construit les différentes périodes
de la journée
c'est des choses qui structurent nos
modes de vie dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui à table demain à 14 heures
sur public sénat public sénat
au coeur du débat
[Musique]